[Music]
over a hundred new psychoactive
substances of emerging each year a rapid
spread which is eluding the law MEP s
want to burn the product suspected of
being dangerous and a tackle organized
crime it's a new era so transia secret
Eva no Xavier mother Quinn delicate oh
no it's a validated civilian Midnapore
internet civilian fabric arancini India
in North German penile asado criminal is
a laminar fracture doll event intent amo
conciencia de la necesidad de Penal
estar aqui na jie
Rousseau mucosal Akhil of India against
a Makarov a connector personal use of
new substances won't be considered a
crime
Bart MEP s want to hold producers
suppliers and distributors criminally
liable with the maximum penalty of at
least 10 years we need to find also with
those organized crimes communities which
are delivering those kind of substances
very dangerous for the people and for
the health and on the other hand we need
to analyze how it is important how it is
dangerous so risk assessment and the
early warning system is needed the
European Parliament is asking for faster
detection and assessment of these
substances the process will be twice as
fast the aim is to respond quickly to
the proliferation of these new drugs
more so since criminal groups act fast
themselves responding to new
restrictions by creating even newer
formulas not yet covered by the law it's
a difficult task because EU countries
used to tackle the issue at national
level the new law aims to improve
cross-border cooperation
[Music]